Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we will see how this AI-based technique
can help our virtual characters not only learn
new movements, but they can even perform them
with style.
Now, here you see a piece of reference motion
- this is what we would like our virtual character
to learn.
The task is to then, enter a physics simulation
where try to find the correct joint angles
and movements to perform that.
Of course, this is already a challenge because
even a small difference in joint positions
can make a great deal of difference in the
output.
Then, the second, more difficult task is to
do this with style.
No two people perform cartwheels exactly the
same way, so would it be possible to have
our virtual characters imbued with style,
so that they, much like people, would have
their own kinds of movement?
Is that possible somehow?
Well, let’s have a look at the simulated
characters.
Nice, so this chap surely learned to at the
very least reproduce the reference motion,
but let’s stop the footage here and there
and look for differences.
Oh yes, this is indeed different.
This virtual character indeed has its own
style, but at the same time, it is still faithful
to the original reference motion.
This is a magnificent solution to a very difficult
task.
And the authors made it look deceptively easy,
but you will see in a moment that this is
really challenging.
So how does all this magic happen?
How do we imbue these virtual characters with
style?
Well, let’s define style as a creative deviation
from the reference motion, so it can be different,
but not too different, or else, this happens.
So, what are we seeing here?
Here, with green, you see the algorithm’s
estimation of the center of mass for this
character.
And our goal would be to reproduce that as
faithfully as possible.
That would be the copying machine solution.
But, here comes the key for style.
And that key is using spacetime bounds.
This means that the center of mass of the
character can deviate from the original, but
only as long as it remains strictly within
these boundaries.
And that is where the style emerges!
If we wish to add a little style to the equation,
we can set relatively loose spacetime bounds
around it, leaving room for the AI to explore.
If we wish to strictly reproduce the reference
motion, we can set the bounds to be really
tight, instead.
This is a great technique to learn running,
jumping, rolling behaviors, it can even perform
a stylish cartwheel and backflips.
Oh yeah.
Loving it.
These spacetime bounds also help us retarget
the motion to different virtual body types.
And furthermore, it also helps us salvage
really bad quality reference motions and make
something useful out of them.
So, are we done here?
Is that all?
No, not in the slightest!
Now, hold on to your papers because here comes
the best part.
With these novel spacetime bounds, we can
specify additional stylistic choices to the
character moves.
For instance, we can encourage the character
to use more energy for a more intense dancing
sequence, or, we can make it sleepier by asking
it to decrease its energy use.
And I wonder if we can put bounds on the energy
use, can we do more, for instance, do the
same with, for instance, body volume use.
Oh yeah!
This really opens up new kinds of motions
that I haven’t seen virtual characters perform
yet.
For instance, this chap was encouraged to
use its entire body volume for a walk, and
thus, looks like someone who is clearly looking
for trouble.
And this poor thing just finished their paper
for a conference deadline and is barely alive.
We can even mix multiple motions together.
For instance, what could be a combination
of a regular running sequence, and a bent
walk?
Well, this.
And if we have a standard running sequence,
and a happy walk, we can fuse them into a
happy running sequence.
How cool is that?
So, with this technique, we can finally not
only teach virtual characters to perform nearly
any kind of reference motion, but we can even
ask them to do these with style.
What an incredible idea.
Loving it!
Now, before we go.
I would like to show you a short message that
we got that melted my heart.
This I got from Nathan, who has been inspired
by these incredible works and he decided to
turn his life around, and go back to study
more.
I love my job, and reading messages like this
is one of the absolute best parts of it.
Congratulations Nathan, thank you so much,
and good luck!
If you feel that you have a similar story
with this video series, make sure to let us
know in
the comments!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!